was nun herr merz nach zwei vergeblichen
anläufen parteivorsitzender zu werden
und 20 jahre nach ihrem showdown mit
angela merkel hat die cdu sie heute
gewählt endlich
95% man hat ihnen gesehen angesehen wie
sehr sie das anfasst was stand da im
vordergrund genugtuung
nein das war nicht genug tun das war
freude aber auch respekt auch ein
bisschen emotionale bewegung was hat sie
so angerührt na ja schon das ergebnis in
dieser größenordnung hätte ich nicht
damit gerechnet
ich hatte so gehofft
80 85 wäre schön wenn es die wird aber
das ist zum 90 werden die ich nicht
geglaubt und 16 jahre darauf gewartet ja
ich habe ja eigentlich vor wie lange ist
es jetzt her im jahr 2009 vor zwölf
jahren eigentlich gesagt ich gehe nicht
nochmal in die politik zurück und dann
ist es anders gekommen ein triumph 95
prozent allerdings ja im dritten anlauf
was ist denn ihre erklärung brauchte es
erst diese krachende niederlage bei der
bundestagswahl damit alle merken
friedrich merz ist der einzige der die
cdu retten kann also ist es nicht es
gäbe sicherlich auch andere die das
könnten aber es hat natürlich völlig
andere umstände gegeben bei dieser
warnung bei diesem parteitag wir sind in
der opposition
wir haben die bundestagswahl 2021
verloren und die beiden vorangegangenen
parteitage der parteitag in hamburg 2018
und auch der parteitag in berlin hier in
berlin in der messe 2021 waren noch
während der aktiven regierungszeit und
die partei ist auch in der basis nicht
beteiligt gewesen das waren diesmal auch
anders und insofern völlig andere
voraussetzungen für einen völlig anderen
parasiten gehörtes war ein bisschen
ironie darin denn sie sind natürlich
jetzt schon das pflaster für für die
wunden der cdu ist das übergangsmäßig
ich habe zunächst einmal den ehrgeiz
etwas zu schaffen was meine beiden
vorgänger leider nicht geschafft haben
nämlich eine volle amtszeit von zwei
jahren zu machen und dann sicherlich
auch darüber hinaus wichtig ist dass die
partei jetzt mal zur ruhe kommt auch
wieder zur arbeit zurückkehrt ich habe
mal gesagt die partei ist denkt voll
geworden das wollen wir jetzt ändern wir
wollen jetzt wieder an den themen
arbeiten und dann wollen wir wahlen
gewinnen wir haben in diesem jahr vier
landtagswahlen die sind für die cdu von
großer bedeutung und dann steuern wir
auf die europawahl im jahr 2024 zu
unseren auf die bundestagswahl 2025 geht
jetzt schrittweise friedrich merz und
die cdu das ist eine lange geschichte
zurück in die zukunft das war das image
das irgendwie an ihnen klebt sie haben
heute versucht kraftvoll nach vorne zu
schauen jetzt auch mit dem kalender den
sie so aufzählen kann der konservative
knochen platz das ist ja eigentlich das
image des ewig lebt kann der ab jetzt
wirklich für aufbruch für erneuerungen
verfügung stehen naja also an diesem
image haben wir nun auch viele
mitgewirkt ob er sie auch ein bisschen
oder also schon jetzt lassen wir mal die
vergangenen vergangenheit sein dieser
konservative knochen den sie da
beschreiben der war ich nie ich bin
natürlich durch und durch ein
bürgerlicher mann ich bin auch jemand
der viel davon hält dass wir
institutionen auch unsere gesellschaft
nicht ohne not infrage stellen aber wir
stellen uns natürlich auch dem
gesellschaftlichen wandel ich auch
völlig klar ich habe familie ich habe
kinder enkelkinder ich sehe doch was da
läuft nein wir wollen jetzt diese partei
einfach wieder auf die höhe der zeit
bringen wir wollen themen besetzen und
ich habe das in meiner rede heute gesagt
wir wollen den zeitgeist nicht ertragen
und hinnehmen sondern wir wollen ihnen
gestalten jetzt haben sie vorhin schon
gesagt was das alles nicht gab in den
letzten jahren geht es am ende dann doch
darum die ära merkel zu überwinden sie
haben ja mal die merkel-regierung 2019
so viel vergangenheitsbewältigung muss
noch sein man grottenschlecht genannt na
gut wenn diese regierung richtig gut
gewesen wäre dann hätten wir die
bundestagswahl gewonnen aber das haben
wir nicht und deswegen stehen wir jetzt
an eine zäsur wir machen einen neuanfang
wir sind in der opposition wir nehmen
diese rolle an und wir wollen aus dieser
rolle auch schnell wieder heraus und je
besser wir diese rolle annehmen hier
schneller sind wieder da ist doch was
zwischen ihnen und angela merkel hat in
dieser woche werden sie zitiert sie habe
sich ausschließlich tagespolitisch
geländegängige im regierungshandeln
unterworfen das sei merkel gewesen haben
sie diese woche der süddeutschen gesagt
wie gehen sie mit angela merkel um sie
scheint ja auf distanz mit ihnen zu
bleiben also wir waren nicht beim partei
hat sich nicht zu schalten lassen hat er
mich geredet und kommt heute abend nicht
zu diesem großen essen das was
dazwischen er frei das was ich da gesagt
habe ist nicht auf angela merkel bezogen
gewesen sondern ist auf die
regierungstätigkeit
sie war die chefin aber sie war nicht
die einzige die daran mitgewirkt hat die
partei ist natürlich in der regierung
einem gewissen verschleiß prozess
ausgesetzt das ist völlig normal ich
habe ja nun auch schon 1998 99 den
regierungswechsel miterlebt und da war
es genauso in der regierung verschleißt
das bild einer partei also zwischen
besteht nicht wir reden vernünftig
miteinander wenn wir uns sehen aber das
ist es auch mit muss es auch nicht sein
vielleicht stehen aber doch noch ein
paar problematische märz fans zwischen
ihnen
ich will es mal so ausdrücken die
ausgesprochen rechtslastige werte union
ist keine cdu abteilung aber da gibt es
viele fans wütet mehr denn je
zerstörungswerk ist da davon ist die
rede hans-georg maßen empfiehlt ihn sich
von den zitaten kilian ischen
hofschranzen zu verabschieden und alle
diese finden märz richtig weil er eben
der anti merkel ist also sie zitieren
jetzt zwei
cdu-mitglieder von 400.000 und sie haben
es völlig richtig gesamtlage und ein
paar männer sind ein paar mehr mit
abnehmender zahl und mit abnehmendem
einfluss ich habe manche kritik nicht
verstanden ich habe manche kritik
nachvollziehen können aber wir haben
heute ein parteitag gemacht mit einer
kompletten neuaufstellung der führung
und ich bin ja nicht nur selbst neu
gewählt worden sondern wir haben große
teile der führung der partei
ausgetauscht wir haben zwei drittel des
präsidiums neu wir haben große teile des
bundesvorstandes neu wir sind insgesamt
die jünger geworden sehr viel weiblicher
geworden wir haben die ersten ziele in
der öffnung der partei erreicht und
diesen weg werden ich habe es einfach
aber ich will noch mal nachfragen also
sie ignorieren die aber sie distanzieren
sich nicht auch jetzt wieder wissen sie
wenn ich mich von jedem einzelnen
cdu-mitglied distanzieren würde was mal
etwas sagt was uns nicht gefällt dann
wäre ich den ganzen tag nur dabei mich
zu distanzieren da nicht ein bisschen
nein nein
da wird auch einige cdu mitglieder eine
prominente rolle zugeordnet die sie
nicht haben der eine den sie eben
genannt haben hat für den bundestag
kandidiert und ist in einem wahlkreis
den wir früher immer gewonnen haben
nicht gewählt worden das ist doch
antwort genug aber müssen sie ihnen da
nicht das ist ein mann der ständig
provoziert wir reden über hans georg
maßen sie haben den namen gar nicht in
den mund genommen provoziert er segelt
hat am rechten rand müssten sie nicht
klare verhältnisse schaffen statt ihn so
zur seite zu schieben was heißt clara
sánchez das heißt also provozieren ist
nach unserer satzung und nachdem
parteien recht der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch kein ausschlussgrund
zum provozieren gehören immer zwei einer
der es tut und einer der sich darauf ein
dass also lassen sich davon lassen
solange sie ihn drin lassen geht noch
das signal von dieser entscheidung aus
für solche positionen ist platz in der
cdu selbst wenn es nur wenn sie auch wir
unterliegen der goßen normal verteilungs
kurve auch bei uns gibt es menschen die
gedanken haben die wir nicht alle teilen
aber das ist doch für sich genommen noch
kein ausschlussgrund so ich habe heute
im präsidium und auch im bundesvorstand
gesagt wir hatten schon konstituierende
sitzung wir reagieren auf so etwas jetzt
inklusive nicht dringend empfehlen die
partei zu verlassen wenigstens dass das
ist seine entscheidung und ich finde
jetzt haben wir schon genug über den man
jetzt gucken wir mal in die in die ost
landesverbände in sachsen hat die cdu
sieben direktmandate an die fdp verloren
bei der bundestagswahl genauso dort wie
in thüringen wird natürlich in den
landtagsfraktionen durchaus auch
geliebäugelt mit einer zusammenarbeit
irgendwie geartete mit der afd trauen
sie sich vielleicht auch deshalb da
nicht anmaßen ran um dort nicht noch
mehr wähler ich bin ja in thüringen
gewesen auch in allen anderen
bundesländern im osten ich habe meine
haseloff im letzten jahr bei seiner
landtagswahl eng begleitet und reiner
haseloff hat etwas gemacht was ich als
vorbild nehmen für uns alle mit einer
ganz klaren abgrenzung und auch einer
klaren aussage dass es zu einer
zusammenarbeit mit dieser partei nicht
kommt ein überragendes wahlergebnis
erzielt alle liebäugele mit diesen
leuten führt für uns nur ins elend und
deswegen ist meine ganz klare botschaft
wir machen da keine zusammenarbeit es
gibt keine übereinstimmung und wir
werden unseren christdemokratischen weg
gehen natürlich auch mit menschen die
konservativ die wertkonservativ sind und
denken wie haben bei uns eine politische
heimat aber nicht diejenigen die
rechtsradikale die bundestagswahlen
haben wir schon gesprochen da haben sie
viel in der mitte verloren auch an spd
und grüne das stellen ihre
sozialpolitiker fest und die befürchten
beim vorsitzenden märz zu viel markt und
zu wenig mitgefühl da lachen sie aber
welches konkrete projekt haben sie sich
vorgenommen um den vorwurf zu entkräften
gibt es da ein leuchtturm wo sie sagen
wir sind jetzt beweisen dass wenn ich
heute bei dieser wahl 75 prozent
bekommen hätte und dann wäre ihre
befürchtung begründet gewesen dass es
einen nennenswerten teil in der union
gibt der so denkt wie sie das gerade
sagen aber mit 95 prozent ist die frage
beantwortet wie haben ihnen kredit
gegeben und sie erwarten trotzdem was
sozusagen das ist offensichtlich recht
ja sogar meine fresse völlig zu recht so
und ich habe das mal in meiner rede
gesagt wirtschaft ist nicht alles aber
ohne wirtschaft werden wir weder unseren
sozialstaat aufrechterhalten können noch
die große transformation hin zum
ökologischen umbau unserer
volkswirtschaft ich habe zwei konkrete
projekte genannt die wir anpacken müssen
wir müssen die sozialen
sicherungssysteme
generationengerecht machen das sind sie
nicht und wir müssen das alte
versprechen der christlichen soziallehre
einlösen nämlich die beteiligung der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer am
produktivkapital unserer volkswirtschaft
das ist für mich eine frage die ich
schon seit langen jahren immer wieder
auch artikuliert habe ich bin jetzt
hoffentlich in der lage das als
vorsitzender auch mal mit konzert
dadurch zu setzen sie das profil
schärfen aber das ist ja nicht leicht
denn sie haben es ja jetzt mit einer spd
geführten regierung zu tun die für
günstige mieten kämpft die den
mindestlohn einführt im oktober 12 euro
der kanzler persönlich hat das zu seiner
zu seinem thema gemacht da wird es
schwer sich zu profilieren muss jetzt
die cdu mit märz
sozialdemokratisiert werden die cdu mit
märz muss wieder christdemokratische
politik machen und die wird sich dann
auch von selbst erklären und wir grenzen
uns nicht gegen andere ab sondern wir
haben unsere haben unsere eigenen
vorstellungen wie wir diese dinge machen
und ankündigen tut diese koalition viel
schauen sie
scholz steht im deutschen bundestag und
erklärt er sei für eine impfpflicht und
weigert sich mit seinem kabinett dem
deutschen bundestag ein gesetz dafür
vorzulegen also diese ankündigungen die
erschreckend welche über corona heimat
sprechen wir gleich noch einen moment
bleibt nur noch bei der sozialpolitik
sie haben eben das stichwort rente schon
angedeutet sicherung der sozialsysteme
stehen sie eigentlich noch zu ihrer
alten idee rente mit 70 dass es so märz
um das jahr 2000 damit die jungen nicht
zu sehr belastet werden damit das system
zukunftsfest bleibt oder wird friedrich
merz als vorsitzender jetzt auch zum
politiker der zumutung er scheut wir
werden unserer gesellschaft etwas
zumuten müssen wir müssen uns selber
etwas zumuten auch in der anpassung und
veränderung auf die zukunft dazu zählt
dass wir zum beispiel mal verabredete
regeln einhalten wir hatten mal die
verabredung dass die rente mit 67
beginnt davon ist in den letzten jahren
leider in der großen koalition manche
abstrich wieder gemacht worden das ist
wieder rückgängig gemacht worden also
kommt mir doch bitte erst mal da hin wo
war 170 gesetzlich nächsten zwei jahren
also ich schließe nichts aus aber ich
kündige auch nicht ohne not an wir
werden noch mal alles auf den prüfstein
stellen müssen auf den prüfstand und die
entscheidende frage ist doch wie gehen
wir eigentlich mit der tatsache um dass
die menschen immer älter werden und dass
die älteren jetzt den großen teil
unserer bevölkerung ausmachen dass die
jüngeren diese altersversorgung zahlen
müssen uns selber große unsicherheit
haben wo sie denn ihre altersversorgung
herkommen sollen so und deswegen werden
wir über diese themen reden wir werden
dann aber nicht punktuell sagen da
machen wir mal was und da machen wir mal
so sondern wir wollen ein konzept
entwickeln wie wir unser rentensystem
zukunftsfähigen haben wir jetzt andere
europäische länder länder längst
geschafft wir liegen hier wahrscheinlich
20 bis 30 jahre zurück in deutschland
das aufzuholen wird sehr sehr schwierig
und deswegen habe ich heute auch in
einer rede gesagt das wird
wahrscheinlich der anstrengendste teil
unserer sozialpolitik an dieser stelle
antworten zu geben die wirklich aber sie
sind ja nicht in der regierung sondern
müssen die ideen in der opposition
entwickeln 1 punkt weiter vielleicht
noch wir hören schon raus breiter mitte
kurs den wollen sie einschlagen dazu ja
auch die verjüngung der partei schaffen
dazu mehr frauen in wichtige position in
der cdu bringen als generalsekretären
sie jetzt aber man vorgeschlagen mario
czaja der heute auch ein sehr gutes
ergebnis bekommen hat freut aber
trotzdem die frage warum haben sie diese
gelegenheit dann doch nicht genutzt
ausgeschlagen ein klares signal an die
frauen in ihrer partei in der
wählerschaft ich habe ein klares signal
an die frauen gegeben dass sich auch
heute in den wahlergebnissen
niederschlägt wir haben wie gesagt sehr
viel mehr frauen in der führung der
union mehr als je zuvor ich habe
aber die ist sowieso die des bundes nach
ist kein überhaupt kein votum gegen die
frauen im gegenteil es ist ein sie ist
weiter mitglied des bundesvorstandes als
mit als loser frauen union ihre
stellvertreterin ist ins präsidium der
partei gewählt worden weitere zwei
frauen sind ins präsidium gewählt worden
also wir haben da schon einen wirklich
großen schritt
die frage ist berechtigt darüber habe
ich lange nachgedacht
ich habe ein anforderungsprofil für mich
selbst entwickelt was ich erwarte wenig
haben möchte und ich habe mario czaja
jemand gefunden die aus dem osten kommt
der aus einer großstadt kommt er an
wahlkreis zurückgewonnen hat überhaupt
jemals erstmalig gewonnen hat dem früher
die linkspartei 30 jahre lang besetzt
hat der großstadt kann der ein profil
miteinander verbindet das genau dem
entsprechen was ich habe
doch ich habe lange gesucht und mir oft
die frage gestellt wie ich die
kombination mache und wie ich sie
optimal aufstellen und ich habe mich
irgendwann mal von dem zwang auch
innerlich gelöst dass es nun unbedingt
eine frau werden muss wir tun ja auch
den frauen keinen gefallen wenn wir
profile entwickeln den sie nicht
entsprechen und trotzdem holen wir sie
dann als anders herum da gibt es auch
die these dass man sich vielleicht dann
doch zwang auferlegen ja und deswegen
gucken sie das schauen sie hin wir haben
die karen brien die die jetzt prien
jetzt neu ins präsidium geholt ist eine
ausgewiesene politikerin aus der
landespolitik die bildungspolitik
beherrscht die in schleswig holstein
einen richtig guten job macht dort und
an der stelle setze ich an für mich
kommt qualifikation vor geschlecht zu
unserer sendung gehört die satz
ergänzung sie kennen das wir geben einen
halbsatz vor und sie ergänzen möglichst
kurz der erste halbsatz lautet dass
atomkraft noch einmal eine option für
deutschland wird ist im augenblick kein
thema die atomkraft als grüne
energiequelle einzustufen ist eine idee
der eu kommission die ich nachvollziehen
können eine rückkehr zur allgemeinen
wehrpflicht um die bundeswehr zu stärken
steht im augenblick nicht auf der
tagesordnung und wenn überhaupt sollte
es im zusammenhang mit einer allgemeinen
dienstpflicht diskutiert werden einen
nato-beitritt der ukraine bis auf
weiteres auszuschließen wie es markus
söder heute fordert war richtig schon
auf dem nato-gipfel 2008 in bukarest als
das das erste mal beschlossen wurde war
das heute abgestimmt mit ihm dieser
vorstoß dass die ukraine eben nie haben
darüber gesprochen
nord stream zwei als drohmittel gegen
russland einzusetzen und nicht in
betrieb zu nehmen ist ultima ratio wenn
russland jetzt wirklich zu einem angriff
zu einer kooperation der ukraine über
geht nach den abgründen die das münchner
missbrauchs gutachten offenbart hat
werde ich als katholik
noch mehr beschwert als vorher schon
dies ist etwas was mich persönlich sehr
berührt serbe trifft sehr beschwert und
offen gestanden ich weiß keinen guten
aussichten kardinäle zurücktreten
das muss zunächst in den kirchen
entschieden werden aber ich gehe davon
aus dass das auch in zukunft gegenstand
von verfahren der ordentlichen gerichte
sein wird und der letzte halbsatz dass
es eine allgemeine corona impfpflicht
braucht ist die meinung der
bundesregierung die sie bis jetzt uns
gegenüber auch mir gegenüber nicht
ausreichend gut begründet hat vor allem
im vollzug wie ist denn tatsächlich dann
in der praxis aussehen soll der
begründung bedarf die fehlt aber dann
müsste die unions-bundestagsfraktion da
nicht jetzt einen eigenen antrag mit
ihrer eigenen position auch zum register
einbringen damit die union der die
position der union in der debatte
wirklich vorkommt und da sich deswegen
die bundesrats ist eine option über die
wir in der nächsten woche sprechen
werden und zu meiner freude muss ich
feststellen gibt es in der
unionsfraktion ganz offensichtlich eine
sehr einvernehmliche auffassung dass
ohne ins register eine solche
impfpflicht in deutschland nicht
zufrieden aber wenn ich das gäbe wären
sie dann dafür dass ist 60 es wäre
jedenfalls eine option ich bin geneigt
ja zu sagen ich sehe aber die vollzugs
pläne ich sehe auch die nachrichten die
ich bekomme die e mails die ich bekomme
nicht von von notorischen impfgegnern
von querdenkern sondern von ernsthaften
menschen die sagen passt ein bisschen
auf was ihr da macht ich passau und der
eigene antrag kommt wir reden darüber
wir denken darüber nach aber zunächst
einmal ist die bundesregierung in der
verpflichtung zumindestens die fragen zu
beantworten die wir gestellt haben
wissen sie wir haben der bundesregierung
vor weihnachten 50 fragen gestellt zu
diesem themenkomplex wir haben nicht
eine einzige beantwortet bekommen und
ich finde das kann man von einer
bundesregierung erwarten auch von einem
bundeskanzler der sich öffentlich
hinstellt durchaus respektabel und sagt
ich möchte die allgemeine impfpflicht
einführen da muss aber auch sagen wie
den antrag vorbereiten müsste brinkhaus
als fraktionsvorsitzender wenn sie ein
kraftvoller oppositionsführer sein
wollen und man hat ja heute ihre ersten
attacken auf gerade gegen olaf scholz
schon gehört dann müssen sie doch jetzt
zugreifen auch nach dem fraktionsvorsitz
kreis ist eine frage die im augenblick
nicht ansteht und wenn sie ansteht reden
wir darüber aber wissen sie nicht
gelernt vor diesen vier wichtigen
landtagswahlen die erste mal eine frage
die im augenblick nicht auf der
tagesordnung steht und wenn sie auf der
tagesordnung steht besprechen wir sie
und wir besprechen es sicherlich nicht
über ankündigung über die medien gibt es
ergibt das ergebnis von heute 95 prozent
ihnen rückenwind dazu das ist jedenfalls
keinen gegenwind die nächsten wahlen
kommen jetzt ja in der tat schnell
saarland dann im mai schleswig holstein
und nordrhein westfalen und es sind ja
auch ihre ersten wahlen also dann werden
sie daran gemessen sie wissen dass
selbst in der cdu zählt am ende immer
der was der die siege einfährt also wie
wichtig ist es dass sie alle drei
wichtige landtagswahlen die fangen an
den im saarland am 27 dritter sind dort
die landtagswahl mit tobias hans der ein
außergewöhnlicher erfolgreicher und
guter ministerpräsident ist wir werden
ihn unterstützen
aber es gilt wie immer in den ländern
müssen die wahlen gewonnen werden wir
wollen sie gewinnen und wir werden sie
unterstützen das war was nun auch heute
wieder nach zweig plus regeln vielen
dank herr merz vielen dank für ihr
interesse liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer hier geht's weiter mit baris
für rares schönen abend noch chips aus
penig
[Musik]